[موسيقى]
مرضى الكلى عاده يقسمون الى مرضى الكلى
الحاده ومرضى الكلى المزمنه الاشخاص
المصابين
ننصحهم بعدم الصيام وذلك بسبب انه الكليه
مصابه باذيه حاده والصيام من شانه ان
يفاقم هذه الاذيه بالمقابل نسمح لهم
بالصيام في حال تم التعافي وتم العوده
للقيام الطبيعيه للكلاب بالاضافه الى
اشراف الطبيب المعالج
المرضى ذوي الاصابه الكلوي المزمنه
ننصحهم بالصيام الا من تجاوزوا الدرجه
الثالثه بمعنى المصابين بامراض الكلى
المزمنه اللي هم درجه ثالثهما فوق بننصحهم
بعدم الصيام وذلك الكليه مصابه باذيه
مزمنه بنفس الوقت وغير قادره على الاحتفاظ
لسوائل الجسم والصيام من شانه ان يعرض
الكليه بهذه المرحله لاذيه حاده فوق
المزمنه
بالنسبه للاشخاص المصابين بامراض الكلى
الذين يتعرضون للغسيل الدموي سواء جلسه او
اثنين او ثلاثه بالاسبوع فهؤلاء ننصحهم
بالصيام خارج ايام الغسيل الدموي كون
الايام اللي بيتعرضوا فيها للغسيل الدموي
من شانها ان تفسد الصيام بالسوائل
المستخدمه اثناء جلسات الغسيل
[موسيقى]
ننصح عاده مرضى الكلى خلال فتره الصيام
ومن سمح لهم بصيام خلال فتره الصيام ان
يبتعدوا عن تناول الاطعمه التي تحتوي على
كميات كبيره من الصوديوم والبوتاسيوم
والفسفور
وبتناول الماء المسموح لهم عبر كاس الماء
وليس عبر
القنيني وذلك لانه الكميه تكون محدده
وننصح دائما
باستشاره ما الطبيب المعالج من اجل ان
تكون الامور تحت السيطره
[موسيقى]